6 24 on your monday morning got a
limited edition return engagement of
deja vu all over again so the idea of
the nevada department of transportation
shutting down eastern under the freeway
really shouldn't be a shocker they've
already done it a couple of times work
continuing on what's officially known as
the i-515 rehabilitation project that we
affectionately called the big squeeze
but what's different about the upcoming
closure is the duration a lot shorter
instead of a full work week of
workarounds this one is going to last
less than 24 hours starting at 8 o'clock
tonight you're going to be doing more
work on the reconstruction of the
freeway bridge over eastern now you're
supposed to get those lanes back at noon
tomorrow and even though it may come as
a shock when it ends up happening if i
keep saying it often enough it might not
be so bad this project is completely
separate from what will eventually be
the reconstruction of the entire 95 515
in that area that project the downtown
access project will make the big squeeze
seem quaint now we've got the link to
ndot's long-term downtown access project
on our website eightnewsnow.com you
click traffic then driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone if there is something
driving you crazy email me traffic 8
8newsnow.com